jetzt ist das das erste Bild vom
messerkiller von Ludwigshafen das hat
uns jetzt erreicht und zwar direkt nach
der Tat wurde es gemacht das ist das
Handyfoto eines Zeugen und man sieht in
den 25 Jahre alten Mann aus Somalia eben
Sekunden vor dem Moment als er Menschen
getötet hat
ja und in seiner Hand da sehen wir
dahinter in diesem Moment auch immer
noch das Küchenmesser das ist die
Tatwaffe die Klinge in diesem Moment
nach hinten gestreckt ja was wissen wir
über diesen Mann über diesen
messerkiller von Ludwigshafen
hier flüchtet der Somalia nach dem
Doppelmord im Blutrausch soll er allahu
akbar gerufen haben das erste Foto des
Täters es zeigt den 25-Jährigen so Maja
noch mit der Tatwaffe in der Hand
ähnlich wie islamistische Attentäter es
bei ihren Taten tun der Wahnsinn von
Ludwigshafen Terror oder Amok
wer ist der Mann der einen 35-Jährigen
Familienvater offenbar wahllos in den
Hals sticht ihm sogar die Hand abhackt
bislang gibt es keine Angaben zu dem
Täter über seinen Aufenthaltsstatus wann
er wie ins Land gekommen ist wie ist
dein Aufenthaltsstatus wer ist der Mann
und warum gibt es keine Informationen zu
dem 25-Jährigen der die abgehackte Hand
seines Opfers seiner Ex-Freundin auf den
Balkon wirft
vor dieser Schreckenstat versucht der
vergeblich in die Wohnung seiner examira
und seinen Töchtern einzudringen doch
die lässt ihn nicht rein es ist der
Anfang eines fürchterlichen Blutbads
auf seine Opfer trifft der 200m von der
Wohnung entfernt auf der Straße am
hellichten Tag der Familienvater ist
Malermeister und gerade mit seinem
Angestellten unterwegs als der Somalia
zusticht der 20-Jährige Jonas eilt
seinem Chef zu Hilfe und wird selbst zum
Opfer er stirbt durch mehrere
Messerstiche in die Brust
eine Tat die Deutschland schockiert auch
weil sie so nicht zum ersten Mal
passiert
Würzburg 2021 ein Somalia rennt mit
einem Messer durch die Innenstadt tötet
drei Frauen Offenburg 2018 ein Somalia
ersticht einen Arzt vor einem Supermarkt
verletzt er einen weiteren Passanten und
einen Mann schwer die Polizei kann den
25-Jährigen Täter schließlich stoppen
Macht von ihrer Waffe gebraucht der
islamexperte Ahmad Mansour macht
deutlich 2020 gab es allein fast 20.000
Messerattacken mit fast 100 Todesopfern
demnach sind 39,6 Prozent der Täter
nicht deutsche Staatsbürger etwas
weniger als die Hälfte davon
17,4% sind Zuwanderer eine
differenzierte und sachliche Debatte
darüber ist wichtig
[Musik]
wann der Somalia nach Deutschland kam
die Polizei hält sich bisher bedeckt
doch hätte die Wahnsinns Tat verhindert
werden können
[Musik]